I mean I guess this is a freeway right
this is that main freeway yeah
also we're gonna run to a building no
doubt just follow the cars I think it'll
be fun
yeah call because we know that there
aren't any buildings hey everyone
welcome to potato mode where we take the
most beautiful games and make them look
like mush here with me today is Rob
handler hey say hello you've already
done that I did it on today we are going
to be playing some grand theft auto 5
yeah one of the best looking games out
there especially with the this PC maxed
out right yeah so we have everything
maxed out and what we're gonna do is
take the game turn down to its lowest
settings see how that goes and then
we'll go even further what a beautiful
looking city Los Santos Santos let's
park up over on that on that hilltop
right there that sounds good
beautiful beautiful alright so the first
thing we're gonna do is well just turn
everything down as far as we can in the
game below those settings we'll go into
the graphics and let's just go the
complete opposite direction
oh boy so instead of 1080 we're gonna go
600 be disabled everything that we've
got yes look at all that video memory
your savings dude no matter what our
frame it's gonna be really really nice
really this is low so this is low this
is actually a couple things that this is
not that bad we're a little bit
stretched right now just because of the
aspect ratio is 4 by 3 right as opposed
to 16 by 9 but I think it's it's looking
pretty good right yeah surprisingly I
mean you'd expect like I don't know a
difference yeah well we can actually do
that so one of the other things that we
have in here is also a scaling mode
which allows you to you can increase
like the the density of the pixels or
you can decrease it to 0.5
we'll get you something that looks a
little bit like this oh yeah oh now
we're talking it's almost like there's a
nice looking game underneath it with me
is this almost like a filter in front of
it yeah look at the roads damn this is
this is gta3 no you won't you want to
see gta3
I'll give you gta3 what I'm going to be
doing is I'm going to be adjusting a
couple things in the the settings files
and so this screen here allows me to
edit a couple things the specific ones
I'm looking at are the LOD scale which
is the level of detail uh-huh and so by
changing these values in the LOD scale
the pedestrian LOD bias vehicles and
then also one down here which is the max
LOD scale you can you can start to make
things look a little little strange Oh
what what all right so we got so a lot
of the textures are just or a lot of the
environments and they all have a lot of
things are just kind of not there
anymore let's go somewhere yeah Shai go
check out 1080p should we do that yeah
let's do that
so we got everything nice and crisp
except we're missing oh we're missing a
lot of things here oh man why is this
happening I can't I can't explain I
could not explain this if I had a gun to
my head
we got mud world so delayed this is like
beer goggles oh my god this is I've
never played any of you game like this
oh dude give me the Buzzard and let's go
to the top of the building okay how's it
looking form up here oh my god
the skybox looks beautiful though skybox
you're okay you're all right wait a
second
there was there was a helipad there bad
wow look at that road just ends the
freeway I like I like that you show us
to make them drunk yes basically what he
sees yes that was cool we got him we got
like that distance factored in you
wanted to see him like that all the time
yes oh my god does he have a miniature
baby in his pocket what is that I used
to be a su I believe look how that
turned out it looks like he's got a baby
wrapped in his pocket it's got a smiley
face like it's tucked in they all have a
baby pocket he'll have a baby pocket
what are we looking at though this is
like the side of his yeah no that's that
that's like the right side of his jacket
what the baby [ __ ] what the baby pocket
is I think his arm so in the middle see
the darker kind of line yeah that's the
lining of his of his I don't know you
call it on us oh my god okay white Marty
the white part is on the right is his
actual undershirt and then where's belly
button in the pocket yeah exactly why
would they have it sideways
that's his leather jacket see it's the
same case yeah it's looking a little bit
better than the baby oh this just the
tan flesh colored pants look at that
he's naked that's his belly hair up
there dude
that is horrifying that's his belly that
actually looks like a shirt so I think
you should go with the belly here like
it just doesn't even right pants don't
make the man okay I think we found the
winner
oh my god guns okay so that's your car
that you just ran into I think what oh
I'm sorry I it's I'm having a difficult
time
it oh my god you're right it's right
here oh my god look out world here we
come those are all the cars in the city
I think holy Shh this is an automotive
wasteland
I'm getting a real aunt vibe here yeah I
was gonna say they look like ants just
colonies oh it looks like my kitchen can
you spot me another Buzzard sure thing
hopefully I can find it what did I just
jump over oh my god all right if you can
find it it's probably somewhere in front
of you just just get in I mean I guess
this is a freeway right this is that
main freeway yeah
also we're gonna run to a building no
doubt just follow the cars I think it'll
be fun yeah I could call because we know
that there aren't any buildings it's so
creepy what does this remind me of like
some movie where there's a creepy ass
like it's like part Slenderman yeah
maybe like part Grim Fandango almost
this is significantly more horrifying
turning around and seeing this guy
sprinting towards you there it is yeah
[Music]
where's the closest barbershop by the
way barber shop barber shop barber shop
barber shop god it's so scary
we need a haircut yeah so here it says
it's here let's go up here we go that's
right
that is definitely a cleavage yeah her
cleavage Oh
I mean nothing is gonna matter you don't
know that this is the weirdest world
ever Oh looks great
oh you look way better I like it he's
got a doughnut
I want that doughnut don't I look good
this fights gonna look real weird on the
news oh so creepy when he runs when he
runs like that yeah yeah also let's yeah
let's see what this cutscene looks like
oh you see me in the house you're
standing oh there we go we're kind of oh
if he walks in on these fingers crossed
oh no you know I just thought about
strip clubs oh god I think that's like
that might be a recurring theme in this
show it is always alright well let's go
to the strip club bouncer PA system
these guys having a good time
vanilla that came out all right oh this
is a girl well let's get a drink
oh just the back of everyone's body it
just looks really gross yeah good stuff
all right let's go get a lap dance
obviously oh my god you know to be
honest do you really even need to censor
this cuz this doesn't even look right
it's just a flat texture right
no harm done it just looks like someone
drew what they think of boobs are
beautiful ladies
[Laughter]
[Music]
leave it oh she's so talented so it's
like a banana slug coming down a tree
what am I looking at I think we need a
closer look okay cool
Joey there's your thumbnail hey Julie
everything in my pocket baby should we
find a place to end this yeah we have
you spawn a plane yeah dang it it's
these damn lamppost I'm
[Music]
well can you land on the blimp yes let's
try it okay making my approach Oh Oh
perfect the plane to the ground oh my
god I survived well that's it once again
thank you guys for watching if you have
any games that you'd like to see broken
and kind of stripped of all its
graphical quality you'll leave them in
the comments below and we might just
might get to them but for now we'll see
you all next time
who else is there this that is a woman
right I think so
whoa her bra is oh my god she had a
rough morning okay [ __ ] there's a power
edge of the dress in the dark
give me some slack okay